Okay.
Hillary Clinton.
We've heard from Hillary Clinton.
Hillary Clinton says that Joe Biden should
not concede the election to Donald Trump in
the immediate aftermath of November 3rd.
Under any circumstances.
Until and if it becomes clear that Joe Biden
has actually lost the election.
There's an interesting new interview.
Clinton was interviewed by Jennifer Palmieri
for the Showtime program.
The circus and right wingers are losing their
minds about what Hillary said.
Sean Hannity is feverish.
Lee tweeting about it.
People are going crazy.
It's really not a big deal, actually.
What Hillary Clinton says makes a lot of sense.
And in fact, it shouldn't even be super controversial.
Let's take a look at it, then we'll discuss.
So we've got to have a massive legal operation.
I know the Biden campaign is working on that.
We have to have poll workers.
And I urge people who are able to be a poll
worker.
We have to have our own teams of people to
counter the force of intimidation that the
Republicans and Trump are going to put outside
polling places.
This is a big organizational challenge, but
at least we know more about what they're going
to do.
And, you know, Joe Biden should not concede
under any circumstances because I think this
is going to drag out and eventually I do believe
he will win.
If we don't give an inch and if we are as
focused and relentless as the other side is.
So this is actually good advice.
And Democrats Democrats sometimes are pushovers.
Let's be completely frank.
And there really is no incentive to concede
early period.
Now, people like Sean Hannity and others are
pretending that what Hillary Clinton is saying
is never concede, no matter what, even if
you lose the popular vote and the electoral
vote handily and there's no foul play that
appears to have taken place and there's no
right.
That's not what Hillary Clinton is saying.
Hillary Clinton is astutely pointing out Trump
is not going to concede if it's close.
Trump is going to claim that it's rigged.
Donald Trump is trying to rig it and planning
to rig it.
So why should Joe Biden concede if there's
any possibility that he actually won?
Now, this could be because of mail in ballots
that had have maybe will not yet be counted
as of November 3rd at midnight.
That's one possibility.
It could be because of other types of voter
suppression.
It could be for any number of different reasons.
And I was actually thinking back to the year
2000, which 2000 was sort of the first presidential
election I paid close attention to.
I remember I was in high school and there
were you know, you started to figure out who
are the few right wing kids in my very liberal
high school and who's following politics and
who's not.
And I remember paying close attention to that
election.
It was Bush v. Gore and it came down to Florida.
As many of you may remember, Al Gore won the
popular vote.
Nationally ultimately lost Florida.
And when people think back to that, I was
recently talking to people who misremember
the crux of what happened in the year 2000
in Florida.
A lot of people correctly remember that there
was a recount started in Florida and that
then Republican secretary of state in Florida,
Katherine Harris, got involved.
Ultimately, the Supreme Court stopped the
recount and the state went to George W. Bush
by about 500 votes.
And when people think back now, they often
think if the Supreme Court hadn't stopped
the recount, Al Gore would have won, would
have won Florida and thus would have won the
presidency.
That's not likely the case because there was
a secondary controversy in Florida in the
year 2000.
The details of which people still argue about,
but it was about votes sent in by mail, many
from overseas, a bunch of different scenarios,
a bunch of different ballots which were misplaced
and thrown out and just disappeared.
OK, so the exact details are less relevant
than the realization that in all likelihood,
the recount that was stopped, George W. Bush
was probably going to win that recount if
it had been completed.
The real problem was the problem of the ballots
that were not going to be part of the equation
that were that were gone.
And likewise, in this upcoming election, there
are likely to be a ton of different layers
in the subterfuge, including in absentee ballots,
voter suppression, voter purges, meddling
of different kinds.
Trump trying to use the judges that he so
famously has appointed to his advantage on
and on and on.
And so what Hillary Clinton is suggesting
is not that if Joe Biden loses fair and square,
he never concede.
What Hillary Clinton is suggesting is that
until it is really, truly, all completely
said and done and it is completely clear that
Joe Biden has lost, there is no reason for
Joe Biden to concede now.
I think we also have to remember because people
are going crazy pulling their hair out about
over this, as if Hillary Clinton, Hillary
Clinton is saying something crazy.
Remember that conceding is merely a formality.
Doesn't matter.
Whether the the losing candidate concedes
has no bearing on what happens on January
20th.
And when it might come down to lawsuits and
courts and the opinions of judges, maybe judges
selected by Donald Trump.
You don't want to do anything.
The optics of which might make it easier for
a judge to hand anything to Donald Trump.
And although conceding is merely a formality,
much like running up the score in the popular
vote, these are optics which might provide
cover for a judge to rule in favor of Donald
Trump.
If it comes down to a court and likewise,
this is why I've said we have to run up the
popular vote, you know, in heavily blue states
like California and Massachusetts, there may
be leftists who say not going to vote.
They don't need my vote or vote third party
because Biden's clearly going to win California.
He's clearly going to win Massachusetts.
I disagree.
We have to run up the score, make it harder
for a court to help Donald Trump in any way,
because Donald Trump is going to use every
tactic possible to steal this election.
Joe Biden and the Democrats need to have a
specific plan for exactly how to deal with
every aspect of this ahead of time.
I'm not sure that they do.
Now, let's let's deal just for a moment with
what the right wingers are saying.
Again, people like Hannity and some right
wingers are reacting as if Hillary Clinton
is saying, even if you really lose, don't
concede.
That's not what she's saying.
She's saying she believes Joe Biden is going
to win, but that there will be pressure on
him to concede and foul play such that he
might end up conceding before he's satisfied
that he really lost and that he shouldn't
do that.
I'm the first to tell you Biden may actually
lose.
At least 60 million people are going to be
voting for the reelection of Donald Trump.
Maybe 65 million, maybe 66.
We don't know.
But roughly 60 something million people will
be voting for Trump's reelection.
It's certainly plausible that Trump wins.
And if that's the case, it's not for Joe Biden
to just insist that he really won.
Biden will have to concede, and I'm sure he
will.
And it'll be up to us to deal with the reality
that we have more than 60 million people in
this country who observed the last four years
and said, give me another four.
That's a problem we'll have to deal with.
And it's a serious problem.
But the advice is correct to Joe Biden until
you're actually satisfied that you really
lost.
Don't concede.
And I hope he follows it.
Hopefully it won't even be close.
But there's a real possibility that it will
be.
And those close scenarios, as I'm going to
talk about Friday, are the ones that are going
to be the most difficult legally.
And also the most likely to lead to violence
in the streets, which I don't want to happen,
but I fear is a real possibility if it's close
and Trump says that it's rigged.
I'll deal with that on Friday.
And what is happening in the intervening time
now is everybody's got to figure out how are
you planning to vote?
Are you voting absentee?
If so, are you mailing your ballot or dropping
it off?
Are you voting in person?
What's the plan?
Is it going to feel safe?
How many masks will you be wearing?
So on and so forth.
That's what we can do in the intervening time.
We will have more on this, much more on our
Instagram page.
Make sure you're following us there at David
Pakman show.
And also last night, I got a crazy hate mail
and I posted it to my Instagram, which is
David Pakman.
My question to you is, do you think the hate
mail I posted last night is real or fake?
Take a look at it.
David Pakman on Instagram.
Let me know what you think.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.